dr scott atlas one of president trump's
coronavirus advisor says he is resigning
atlas you may recall dismissed the
impact of the virus and also the need to
wear masks
by the way he has no training in
infectious diseases
and while members of president trump's
team are leaving president-elect joe
biden plans to introduce top members of
his economic team today
former federal reserve chair janet
yellen is his choice to become treasury
secretary
as ed o'keefe reports she will lead a
team with an unprecedented number
of women president-elect joe biden will
formally introduce his nominees today
for key economic jobs including janet
yellen the first woman to be nominated
for treasury secretary
and nira tandon the first woman of color
to be nominated to lead the
office of management and budget tandon
head of the liberal center for american
progress think tank
is already drawing criticism from some
republican lawmakers
she's going to be radioactive they argue
she's been too critical of president
trump and gop lawmakers
on twitter honestly the hypocrisy is out
astounding
if republicans are concerned about
criticism on twitter
their complaints are better directed at
president trump
tandon's confirmation along with the
rest of mr biden's cabinet
will depend on whether or not
republicans keep control of the senate
after georgia's senate runoff elections
in january
as mr biden moves ahead with putting his
cabinet together
president trump's attempts to overturn
the results of the election continue to
be blocked
on monday arizona and wisconsin
certified their election results
we do elections well here in arizona
the system is strong that's arizona
republican governor
doug ducey who joins a growing list of
republicans mr trump is lashing out
against
for not overturning their state's legal
results
on twitter the president called on
georgia's republican governor brian kemp
to overrule georgia's republican
secretary of state
brad raffensberger who's disputed mr
trump's claims
of voter fraud there are those who are
exploiting the emotions of many trump
supporters
with fantastic claims half truths
misinformation and frankly they are
misleading the president
as well apparently and as the president
continues lashing out at some
republicans there are other gop
officials who still don't acknowledge
that joe biden
is the president-elect some of them
facing tough re-elections in two years
others already thinking about campaign
2024.
and as mr biden considers who might lead
the pentagon cbs news has learned
there are three top contenders to serve
as defense secretary
michelle flornoy a obama era defense
official
former army four star general lloyd
austin and former homeland security
secretary
jay johnson no word yet gail on when
exactly the president-elect might make a
pick
all right we're all waiting for that but
can i just ask you about the fighting
with the republicans how
donald trump has turned on the people
that were his allies what do you make of
that you know all the players people are
saying his loyalty only seems to go one
way
uh that would be one way to put it
absolutely look this is a
president who was convinced he would win
these states that were led by republican
governors
that have republican lawmakers and our
other republican elections officials he
just saw that and figured that those
people would help him out
and help him win but seems to forget
that it's american voters who decide
yeah who wins elections yeah let's
always remind people it's the voters who
made this decision
thank you very much ed o'keefe always
good to see you